- Hi, I'm Sal Kahn, founder
of the Kahn Academy.
I'm here to invite you to participate in
an exciting project that
we have around career.
Our mission statement,
as a not for profit,
is to provide a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere.
Part of that is help people
navigate their careers.
What do they want to major in?
What jobs do they want to pursue?
What are the implications on their life
in terms of finance?
This is part of a
partnership that we're doing
with Bank of America.
We're looking for people
in all walks of life,
in all sorts of careers, who are willing
to be videotaped and
answer questions about
how they chose their careers,
the good, the bad, money questions,
how they budget, how much they make.
- Hi, my name is Tamillia James,
and I'm a high school guidance counselor.
- My name's Eddie.
I'm 26 years old, and I
work as a health coach.
- My name is Emmie Kelsey.
I'm 22 years old.
I work as a business associate
at an indoor vertical farming startup.
- My name's Anna Nelson.
I'm 28 years old.
I'm an instructional
designer at a startup.
- A health coach is a
number of different things,
depending on the individual
that we come across.
It can be a motivational interviewer.
It can be an exercise partner.
- We're not like a traditional company
where I have an immediate supervisor
that I get all of my work from.
- Currently I make $90,000 a year.
- When I first started as a
high school guidance counselor
and I was making $50,000.
- When I finally left graduate school,
I had something like $72,000 in debt.
- If you're interested in participating,
you'd like to be on
camera, answering questions
about where you are in your career,
questions about finance,
decisions that you've made,
please click on the link below
and submit either a short video,
or a short written piece
about what you do and why.
(light upbeat music)